as one of a handful of comics who made
the jump straight from the stage to the
movie screen to median actor Dane Cook
was everywhere during the mid arts from
touring stadiums with his raunchy brand
of comedy and appearing in films
opposite Hollywood stars he was on fire
birth a decade later he's reduced to
voicing roles and forgettable Pixar
spin-offs and mounting a modest comeback
on the small screen Cooke still the same
guy who brought us two helpless tears of
laughter all those years ago so where'd
he go and what happened he is how Dane
Cook went from being the king of comedy
to a Hollywood punchline and how he can
turn it all around Hollywood hijinks
released in 2006 at the height of kooks
fame Employee of the Month was poised to
be a huge box-office hit but critics
savaged the film with cooks co-star
Jessica Simpson scoring a Razzie
nomination for worst actress earning a
meager 38 million dollars at the box
office Employee of the Month proved to
be the beginning of trouble for both
cook and Simpsons big-screen careers and
that was just the start of a silver
screen slaughterfest
cook again struck Rati gold with 2007 s
good luck Chuck a forgettable rom-com
which boasts a pitiful 5 percent rating
on Rotten Tomatoes he and Jessica Alba
were nominated for worst screen couple
of the year while Entertainment Weekly
opened its review of the film of the
scathing question can we finally just
admit that Dane Cook isn't funny indeed
the slums kept on coming when his next
big screen comedy my best friend's girl
proved to be a friend to no one DEFCON 2
level of anger the joke thief's
accusations of joke thievery have
plagued cook throughout his career Joe
Rogan accused cook of stealing some of
his material and video comparisons of
bits from Cooks 2007 special retaliation
and Louis CK's 2001 album live in
Houston have circulated on the web for
years cook even appeared as himself on
an episode of Louie in a scene that
addressed a real-life joke stealing
drama you're for Dane even so Cook is
still viewed by his comedian peers as a
lightweight pretty boy who got lucky
Saturday night's live vet Jim Breuer
told today in 2006 not one comedian
comes on my serious radio show and say
I'm so happy for him which is weird they
can't stand this poor guy cooks 2006
album retaliation may have debuted at
number 4 on the Billboard charts and got
on to receive double Platinum
certification but his last album 2010 s
greatest hits compilation I did my best
came in at only number 165 the joke
stealing controversy hasn't helped Cook
revealed to Marc Maron on an episode of
the WTF podcast that same year that he
feels excluded from the rest of the
comedy community but it's not like
there's anywhere else for him to go
because dramatic diss well done in real
life was a modest success critics
singled out Steve Carell zli droll
overcooked supporting turn and his role
opposite Kevin Costner in the serial
killer flick mr. Brooks didn't exactly
well reviewers either with many pointing
to cooks performance as unintentionally
funny he also missed out on some super
opportunities like the role of Marvel
star-spangled hero and Captain America
the First Avenger cooked sedid train to
audition for the role but reportedly
never even made the shortlist
ouch to make matters worse cooks sci-fi
passion project four hundred days
crashed and burned in 2016 earning a
meager $58 at three theaters in the UK
and scoring just 13% on Rotten Tomatoes
[Music]
bad taste and timing in 2012 cook took
some serious heat for a joke he told at
the Laugh Factory a week after the
tragic movie theater shooting in Aurora
Colorado understandably the public was
incensed at the far too soon joke so
cook took to Twitter to apologize saying
I am devastated by the recent tragedy in
Colorado and did not mean to make light
of what happened I made a bad judgment
call with my material last night and
regret making a joke at such a sensitive
time my heart goes out to all the
families and friends of the victims the
damage was already done it took two
years till Dane Cook Showtime special
troublemaker got him back into a smaller
spotlight with him delivering an
intimate set that was a far cry from the
days when he sold out Madison Square
Garden reviews were decent though the
special failed to make much of an
impression outside of cooks dwindling
fan base time for our comeback cooks
career seemed ready for a second wind
when he was cast as a sexist loudmouth
radio DJ paired with a feminist co-host
on the NBC sitcom next caller but the
series was cancelled in 2012 before it
even made its aware but the small screen
could still be the key to Dane Cook's
return to the mainstream
he earned buzz playing an annoying boss
on a recent episode of workaholics and
he's set to play Robby on American guts
stars his adaptation of the acclaimed
and the or Gaiman novel taking a
supporting role in a show that as the
markings of a cult hit could be the
first step towards Dane Cook 2.0 cook
for one certainly believes that all the
low points he's experienced are just
part of the Hollywood pendulum swinging
and he's just gotta hold on till he's
back on top in order for us to like you
again and really believe that you you
know you made it you gotta suck for a
while well at least he's been playing by
the rules then thanks for watching click
the loop icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know your love to
you